malgré la présence à shanghai
d'importants émissaires américains
les négociations n'ont pas abouti à un
accord avec pékin
agacé par la lenteur des pourparlers
dans notre shop ajoute de la pression il
lance une nouvelle salve dans le conflit
commercial avec la chine
les nouveaux tarifs de 10% sur
l'équivalent de 300 milliards de dollars
de produits chinois vous êtes entré en
vigueur le 1er septembre la trêve qu'ils
avaient déclaré en compagnie du
président xi jingping en marge du sommet
du g20 en juin prend donc fin washington
reproche entre autres à la chine de ne
pas acheter suffisamment de produits de
l'industrie agricole américaine comme
elle l'avait promis au secteur se plaint
depuis longtemps des impacts négatifs du
conflit qui limitent l'accès à un énorme
marché d'exportation il ya aussi un côté
chinois cette représentante du
gouvernement accusé plus tôt cette
semaine les américains d'être capricieux
dans le cadre des négociations après
l'annoncé des nouvelles taxes punitives
les principaux indices boursiers
américains ont chuté ce qui n'a pas
ébranlé le président d'un autre homme
confirme que les négociations avec pékin
doivent reprendre en septembre et au
delà de la question des tarifs douaniers
ce sont des changements structurels
majeurs des pratiques économiques
chinoises que la maison blanche veut
obtenir 6 à pékin ont misé sur l'impact
de ce conflit commercial sur les
consommateurs américains à washington le
président juge que c'est la pression
exercée sur l'économie chinoise qui
finira par lui donner raison
difficile donc pour l'instant entrevoir
un dénouement à ces négociations ici
rappelle bouvier auclair radio-canada
washing